hi I'm Maya Hawk I'm here at BuzzFeed to
play with puppies and answer your
questions
[Music]
I feel really really good feel very at
ease oh I should take questions out now
this is not I don't just get to play
puppies I also have to expose my my
inner soul what are some similarities
between you and Robin what are some
differences she's much smarter than me I
do not speak three languages and I'm not
unbanned and I am not nearly as
brilliant and talented as she is but she
really cares about her friends and she
is brave when the time is right she
tries to be funny I don't know if she
succeeds but we both definitely try to
be funny let's see this is so hard to
try to be funny with all these amazing
puppies I was thrilled to spot you and
once upon a time in Hollywood what was
the casting process like was that wrong
well obviously I have kind of known
Quentin my whole life if you want to
answer this one but um I auditioned for
it and I've seen like I made a tape and
I sent it in and I think I probably had
it wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
one question at a time one question at a
time
what's the role you auditioned for word
that you really wanted but didn't get
the new live-action Little Mermaid I
really wanted that like you - hi okay
what can you tease about any upcoming
projects either acting or music I have
some songs that are about to come out in
August that I'm really excited for you
to see I wrote the lyrics and my friend
Jesse Harris wrote the um hi hi wrote
the music and I hope that you like them
what's the last TV show you binge
watched the best season of The
Bachelorette it's pretty great I haven't
seen the last two episode so no spoilers
anyone in the room have you finished it
who did Hannah pick what was it like
working with Joe getting him free
entering the scoob's always you know
like kind of like playing with these
puppies right now they're really funny
and really cute and really fun to be
around
and just in dedicated hard-workers order
don't attack him don't attack him okay
order the scene in the bathroom and
Robin and Steve is one of my favorites
in this time what is it what it was a
difficult to shoot the own so sorry
did you do it in one take we did not do
it in one take there's like six
different pieces of coverage there was
like an over the head of the stalls like
in front of the stalls there's like when
you travel under the stalls it was
really complicated to shoot it was
really fun to act in and it was just me
and Joe and I got to really like pour
our hearts out and most of the season
you're doing a lot like like bits of
like real acting work and bits of like
running from Russians and that seemed
you just have to sit and breathe and be
together and try to tell their story and
it was hey hey no growling ain't no
growling hey no growling and it was
really good and it was really nice and
Joe is a great actor and a really fun
scene partner what has it been like
seeing the response to read Robin being
an LGBTQ character did you know that
Robin was going to be the LGBTQ
character winning you auditioned or was
it something you learned while filming I
learned while filming it was amazing I
was so proud to put an LGBTQ character
on such a mainstream show that people
all over the world in all over our
country in red and blue states alike
watch and I loved her and it felt true
to her and I'm really glad that we did
it I know that people seem to like her
and that's good my wildest dreams all I
could want for them to fall in number
for the way I did since you grew up
around actors yes I did is acting always
something he wanted to do if you weren't
an actor what job would you like to have
maybe like a puppy a puppy handler puppy
caretaker a puppy smuggler I don't know
I wanted to be a farmer I wanted to be a
poet I still want to try directing
there's lots of things I want to try
doing I love acting I've always loved
acting it's always been the place that I
felt most myself and most alive and so I
want to hope I get to do it my whole
life if I'm really lucky but I just went
oh are you a good reader are you the
cutest thing I've ever seen my whole
life yes okay oh my god is there a
stranger things group chat if so what
was the last thing someone sent on it if
there's a stranger's things group chat
I'm not on it but I think there was a
group chat in like season 1 and 2 but in
season 3 I think everyone um just
communicated individually whoo what's
the best piece of advice you've been
given never to lie lying takes a lot of
energy and is always in
always somebody finds out and then it's
embarrassing no lying lying is bad
what's your favorite memory from filming
Little Women yes what a loner question
that was my first job and like my
favorite experience ever
me and all the girls and Jonah Katherine
Newton and Willa Fitzgerald and NSL way
we got so close and made the most
beautiful time in Ireland ever in those
costumes it's like I had the time of my
life I love this scenes its ratings
Robyn Steve were high on the truth serum
what was that like to film any funny
stories in that dance act totally we
were tied to these chairs with these
leather bands it was really
uncomfortable and we were both really
really grumpy and snippy and trying to
do this scene and and we had it like ask
permission to be untied to get up to pee
being tied up is not fun at all but the
scene was so great and then we had to
pretend we were high on drugs and they
just started giggling and he couldn't
stop laughing and it was awesome
are you offended Harry Potter what's
your hardware house I am a giant fan of
Harry Potter I want to be a Gryffindor
like we all want to be a Gryffindor but
I'm probably like a Hufflepuff Ravenclaw
I mean maybe I'm a southerner I just
want to talk the online test and I got
slither in the butt
I think it's just I was in a good mood
it's in a weird place hi hi are you in a
weird place are you in Slytherin
well what was your favorite Disney movie
Cinderella I know it doesn't exactly
have the most positive female role model
but I love singing mice if you play any
superhero or have any superpowers what
would they be I've always been a really
big fan of Avatar The Last Airbender and
I always wanted my superpowers to be
waterbending if you had to be stuck on a
desert on the one member of the stranger
things past would it be absolutely
Gaytan he is a brilliant survivalist and
and and just an intelligent person I
feel like they'd be really good at
helping me build things and survive and
start fires and build rafts I would pick
things what's your favorite book of all
time I do love Harry Potter I also love
Anna Karenina
I also love this book by Marilyn
Robinson called housekeeping this is the
most overwhelming experience of my life
what's your favorite type of music to
listen to what's your favorite song or
album right now my favorite type of
music to listen to is probably like 70s
rock and both music like a love Bob
Dylan I love but right now
really Eilish and I love her and her new
album is awesome so rock on Billy
hi I don't know why I feel like I'm
racing we had saying these questions I'm
like trying to win a win a race what's
your go-to coffee order embarassingly
I'm from New York I'm not from Los
Angeles but it's an Oakland launch a
latte which stranger these character
would you like to see Robin in Rockford
near future Mike for sure is the best
really want to interact with Mike what
scene was the hardest hi oh my god I
want to play too what scene was the
hardest to film on stranger things uh
the definitely the leather strap chair
scene for previously referred to what
was the process like for learning
Russian on strange things did you know
it before I didn't know before and I
don't know it now um the process was
like having someone say those words out
loud to me a hundred times and me repeat
them back until eventually I could say
them what I thought was right and then
it was wrong and I had to fix it an ADR
if there's a season for stranger things
what are your hopes for Robin would you
like to see her have a girlfriend I
would and maybe it could be you could
you be my girlfriend
no that's inappropriate what was your
favorite behind-the-scenes story from
filming stranger things my favorite
behind-the-scenes story ha um right now
I can think about his joke here he has a
really cute dog and my favorite thing
about behind the scenes would hang out
with his really good dog because you
guys are so cute and you would like her
oh what's your favorite ice cream flavor
mint chocolate chip but I like anything
with rainbow sprinkles I always get remo
sprinkles my favorite thing about being
an adult is that I get to ask for extra
rainbow sprinkles if you could travel
anywhere in the world where would you go
I'm dying don't fight me don't play me
you goose I'm dying to go to Japan I've
never been to Japan and I've never been
to South America and I'd love to go to
both of those places there's only one
left I mean maybe there's more because
of all the things the dogs did what's
your favorite TV show and movie of all
time I've ever moved all the time is
Robert Altman's Nashville I just think
it's the most genius movie ever made my
favorite TV show of all time is Grey's
Anatomy because sometimes you need to
cry and it really gets you there
thank you so much this has been a lot of
fun my name is Maya Hawk and make sure
you go check out stranger things on
Netflix all of these puppies are
available at North Shore Animal League
America and they're really cute and
adopt don't shop they're just really
sweet and you should adopt them thank
you bye guys
[Music]